alright well my presentations running a
tiny bit long so I'm gonna go ahead and
get started so my name is TJ Torres and
I'm a data scientist at stitch fix and
so today I was hoping to talk with you a
little bit about some of the recent work
that I've been doing on using kind of a
relatively recent method in deep
learning called variational auto
encoders and using that to kind of
develop a latent style space we're a
women's clothing company so to develop a
late in style space for some of the
image data that we have and i'll go into
what all that means pretty pretty
briefly here so that's a little bit
about me so I'm on the algorithms team
at stitch fix and there we have sub
teams of the algorithms team and I'm on
that one of the teams called data labs
and sort of our purview and data labs is
to do kind of experimental R&D where we
tackle high-risk high-reward ideas and
so that allows me to kind of use some of
these more experimental methods to
analyze images and you know do so in a
business context so just to give you a
little bit of context about what stitch
fix does we're basically just a service
where you can go online and sign up for
an account and order what we call a fix
and in that fix are personally styled
items of clothing for you and then you
you know can try them on do whatever you
wish with them for a little while and
then you send the ones that you don't
like back to us and keep the ones that
you do like so we're doing our job
correctly you know we hope that we could
probably try to like maybe eliminate or
at least reduce the time that you spend
going out and shopping it may be retail
stores alright so the problem with that
business model when it comes to scaling
is that as we try to serve our clients
better and better it means that we need
to have a bunch more inventory in terms
of clothing and so the way that we are
styling for people is we have these
professional stylists they come in they
look at items of clothing and they take
in some information about our clients
and then they pick out items of clothing
for them so as our inventory gets larger
and larger it becomes pretty prohibitive
for people to go through and actually
look through every single item of
clothing and so
the center's kind of the data science
regime where we're using recommendation
algorithms to do sort of pre-filtering
so we just take a subset of those
clothes and then you know present those
to the stylist so that the stylist can
make the best decision possible from
from there on in so if we did that
process perfectly when we had lots of
data we'd still have this next problem
which is called a cold start problem so
this is kind of a problem for everyone
who does recommendation algorithms which
is that when you don't have any data
whatsoever on either you know we have
sometimes we get new clients or new
clothing if we don't have any data on
the unde either of those whatsoever it's
really hard to do any sort of modeling
on them so we don't really know how to
recommend those items of clothing to you
know new clients um so you can really
boil this down into a four-step process
where this ? is a really big question
mark and so it's something that we're
still working on in fact but us but the
way that I am hoping to tackle it is to
do some some modeling with images so
when people sign up for our service they
give us access to their Pinterest boards
and so we get actually quite a bit of
are quite a number of images about kind
of kinds of clothing that they like and
then also you know with our new clothing
we take pictures of every item that we
have so we have images of that as well
so I'm trying to use that to come up
sort of a style space so that we can use
that style space that then do some
future modeling on so with images
basically you know the reason that we
want to use images to begin with right
and the reason that it would be nice
even if we didn't have this cold start
problem is that you know styles pretty
primarily visual and so you know our
window to the world digitally is through
images and so we really want to be able
to use those for our modeling purposes
and to make our recommendation
algorithms better the heuristics with
with which humans process images is
pretty unclear right now you know we we
know somewhat how like our retinas work
and how our brains process that
information to a certain extent but we
really like if I were to describe to you
how I decided that something was for
instance like preppy and
terms of like you know fashion I would
have no idea how to go about doing that
right like maybe I know it when I see it
but I can't really describe to you the
process that I took to get to that
conclusion so so it's pretty hard to
develop sort of a heuristic algorithm to
do this it's also we really don't want
to try to do feature engineering on
images right that that actually requires
quite a bit of domain knowledge both in
image processing and and also in fashion
and the it's kind of surprising that the
overlap between those two isn't super
high so so we're going to turn to
something till kind of do our feature
learning for us or a feature engineering
for us which is to turn to deep learning
for some of these feature extractions
and images all right so just kind of an
outline for the rest of the talk that
was kind of the the stitch fix intro and
now now things are going to move a
little bit more into generality so I'm
going to give just a really brief
introduction on to neural networks and
then I'm going to cover on supervised
processes with those and then I'm going
to use a specific framework called chain
er which I've been really liking just
for its readability it's really nice and
I'll go through a really simple example
of kind of just structuring your first
forward pass through a network in order
to try to train models on images and
then get some sort of output of those so
part of the process when we do these
variational auto encoders you get this
generative process so we can kind of
inspect what's happening in our neural
network which are normally fairly
abstract by looking at what the
generative output is and then i will
discuss a bit about the open source
package that i developed and have put
out there for people to install so that
they can train their own models on their
image sets and i'll show some examples
of things that people have done with it
okay all right so a little bit about
neural networks i'm pretty sure probably
at this point most people have heard
about them here there's this kind of
media sensation over the summer where
you know these images came out from
other generative models from google
these google deep dream images which are
pretty wonderfully trippy but basically
they can be used for a lot of like
really practical
services to write these generative
models allow us to kind of inspect and
see whether or not this is this is from
the draw networks that were also
constructed and and you can see that it
was trained on google street view of
data for address labels and you can see
that if it can reconstruct the data
reasonably well right you you can or or
even these are these are sort of
randomly generated one so if we get
randomly generated images that are quite
similar to our original training set
then we can think that you know the
encoded space or the space that we can
or the vector space that we use for the
modeling process that comes out of these
is probably pretty good right it's at
least memorizing something to do with
with with these images so just a little
bit of an introduction to neural notes
for those of you who don't really know
the ins and outs of how they work this
will be pretty brief but but hopefully
it'll give you a little bit of an
overview so we start with just an input
and the way that neural networks are
structured is they're structured in
layers so we just have layers of neurons
and the neurons just hold pieces of data
so for this specific example I have four
piece or six pieces of data we could say
that maybe this is sixth grade scale
pixels in an image something like that
and then they get filtered through these
lines which are connecting the different
neurons on the top layer to the second
layer in actuality I've only drawn one
set of lines but there should be sets of
lines corresponding to each one of those
second nodes there and so those are just
this is just a linear mapping from the
first input layer to the second so each
one of those lines basically just
represents a number that I'm multiplying
that input data with and then I add in
like usually an additional bias and then
filter that finally through some
nonlinear function and the reason for
filtering it through a nonlinear
function is that if I wanted to do a
functional composition which is
basically what's going to happen as we
filter through more and more layers of
linear functions then the whole the
whole reason that we call them linear
functions is that that ends up being
linear in the end so I want something
that's going to do kind of a non linear
mapping so that I can get something a
bit more a bit more telling about my
data rather than just some kind of pca
like transformation right
so oh that's I mean they're they're
actually a number of different ones used
the one that I'll use later is not a
hyperbolic tangent but yeah that's a
good question i think the the original
motivation is basically the fact that
they kind of model neuron activations so
as like your signal gets to so
hyperbolic tangent right goes from you
know has like kind of this brief spike
so as soon as you get past like a
certain threshold it's activated and
then and if you're below that threshold
it's not really activated so i think
that's kind of the inspiration for why
tangent or hyperbolic tangent or sigmoid
czar used i'm going to be using
rectified linear ones so there's really
no motivation for those beyond the fact
that they're really easily computable
and they're not linear so yeah so we can
filter through and we basically do a
functional composition with these
nonlinear functions and that gives us
something that's really nonlinear and
also an example of that and then we
calculate a loss function something
that's appropriate to our problem so if
we're doing a classification we
calculate a loss function based on how
far off we work from the classification
if we're doing something like we're
going to do later on we want to take the
mean squared error between some
reconstructed image in our original
image and with those with that loss we
can basically do a gradient descent for
these weights to try to minimize that
loss function right so we go back we
kind of calculate this this this is kind
of where the magic happens here right
this gradient for for the loss function
with each one of the weights and update
them and then we can we can sort of see
that this is really just going to
involve a large number of steps in in a
chain rule which is sort of thus the the
name change and and that's it that's
that's all we do we back propagate and
train those weights and over time we
hope to minimize our loss functions so
it's just our objective right we hope to
minimize that in order to do some sort
of task so if it's classification we
hope to minimize the number of
misclassifications and we can train
weights in order to do that optimally so
as you get deeper and deeper basically
I've kind of touched on this before but
that but shallow networks that are you
know non that are not really nonlinear
just approximate PCA basically so all
we're doing with these neural networks
right is we're taking sort of
projections on two different spaces
right so we can think of like our data
lying in this like high dimensional
Euclidean space really what we're
seeking to do is take it into a lower
dimensional space but that lower
dimensional space didn't need to be
necessarily Euclidean space right I can
think of all sorts of manifolds to
project my points on to and so PCA
chooses just hyper planes right and so
that's that can be interesting and it's
certainly useful sometimes but it's also
nice to have things like local linear
embedding and other things that are that
are sort of nonlinear processes and and
neural networks do a really good job
learning these nonlinear manifolds with
which we can like kind of project our
data down on to and so you can do that
with these functional compositions and
I'll show here you know this is just a
sine function on top right which is
nonlinear in and of itself but when you
compose it with a bunch of other signs
you get something that's really
nonlinear right so if you can think of
like maybe I couldn't fit my data with a
sine function but I could fit it with
this really scribbly function right so
that touches on the fact that will come
that will come up later which is that
you know you can you can usually do some
pretty good bit of overfitting when you
have that amount of non-linearity okay
so so yeah so the general process with
which people have been doing this for
quite a while and there are some
unsupervised methods that people been
using to but most of the methods that
you're going to see our deep learning
with supervision right I give you a
label training set and you pass it
through your network and you compare the
output labels to the original labels
that you know I had on my set or my
training set and there are two real real
major portions to networks like this one
of which is kind of the feature
extraction portion and then the other
just deals with they're usually fully
connected and they deal with the
classification part so what we want to
do in the unsupervised case is to take
sort of the feature extraction part and
then kind of throw away the
classification portion
and we'll see how we can do that later
on all right so so firstly as I kind of
mentioned before there are issues for
doing this supervised process with style
right so it is for which like we want to
kind of try to tackle this from an
unsupervised standpoint to begin with
right and the reason is that there's
really no there's no reliable system of
labels so if I ask you you know how
would you describe this shirt and you
ask your friend how they would describe
that shirt usually it's going to be a
pretty different description right and
you know it's really hard to come up
with some vector space with which we can
kind of classify all of our different
images at once so what we're going to do
instead is turn to so so instead of
labeling our images which would be
rather noisy we're going to just turn to
unsupervised learning and so the key to
that's going to the thing that's going
to be the key with this on these
unsupervised processes is to kind of
compress the data and then re expand the
data and kind of compare the re-expanded
data to the original and then that
compressed section will be our latent
space yeah i'll get to that for sure
yeah um don't worry yeah I'm not going
to just leave you there so yeah so with
these unsupervised methods just like if
you were to leave a toddler unsupervised
things can get rather interesting so
auto encoders are pretty much the
primary means by which people do these
unsupervised deep learning methods and
their two processes kind of combined
into one single model one is an encoding
step or an inferential model and the
other is a decoding step or a generative
model so here's what i mean by the
latent space so in this in this diagram
you can see we have this original image
which I've kind of simplified down to
maybe say I had like four pieces of data
that described that image okay usually
you know the images are 100 by 200
pixels and three color channels that's
like 60,000 parameters but this diagram
is very simplified so I start off with a
layer of four neurons and I filter it
down to a layer with three neurons where
I
and I successively filter it down two
layers which have fewer and fewer
neurons until I get to some sort of
bottleneck right and I'm going to call
that my my latent space that's sort of
the space that has you know the
parameters which I find will be
essential to describing what that image
is and what I mean by that is that I
then have to use those parameters to try
to reconstruct the original image right
so if it didn't learn something about
the original image in that compressed
representation I wouldn't be able to
very faithfully reconstruct the image
afterward okay so yeah the output layer
is exactly just an image it's this will
hope we hope the same image yeah the
target is the original image so that's
what we're going to use as like the
target for our loss
yeah the reason that we call these you
know auto encoders right as it means
that they're kind of like being compared
to themselves right so so I take in the
original image I filter it through this
process to compress the data I
decompress the data using a very similar
process right and they don't actually
have to be symmetrical but you know most
people will structure them in
symmetrical reasonably symmetrical ways
and then I compare my you know at first
when I first sort of initialized these
that's just everything is going to be
random right and so the image that I'm
going to get out is going to look an
awful lot like just noise but as I train
this model over time through like
further and further iterations I'm going
to get something which looks a lot more
like that right hand image that I'm
comparing to my original image in the
loss function so and that right hand
image is actually a true to form like
reconstructed image from these models so
well so we're training a model that's
that's generating you know not I don't
just do this with one image right I do
this with a bunch of different images
and then i can pick random points in my
encoded space and see what comes out of
it so that's what i mean when i say it's
a generative model
do you mean like I cannot further
generate anything like more than what
what the compression gives me I mean
that's true that I can't exactly
reconstruct this right but I can I can
do a pretty good job so in the sense
that like in the same sense that like if
I took a PCA of some of my data right
and I I throughout you know there was a
talk yesterday talking about nice
thresholds for like doing these kinds of
eigen value manipulations which is
essentially what PCA is right if I threw
out like you know ninety percent of my
my pc a dimensions and just focused on
the top ones right I would be doing the
same thing I'm still compressing my data
and hopefully I get something that's
reasonably good at giving me back my
original image but what I mean by its
generative is that there is actually an
inverse process right if I were to just
completely cover this up after I trained
it right and i put in random parameters
here i can generate wholly new images
from that and so i'll show some examples
of that later on ya know that's it's a
really good question so the question is
how do i know how many how many latent
dimensions to reduce to and the answer
to that is practice like yeah I you you
really just have to kind of play around
with it and decide what for a specific
data set how how wide you want to be
able to encode to so for this model I
think this was i want to say 30
parameters 30 layton parameters so down
from 60,000 it's not bad okay so there
are some issues with these auto encoders
right and then one of the issues is that
they often will over fit the data
there's another issue about gradient
decay but I'm not going to go into that
too much and so really the the new thing
that I'm doing here right those are just
auto encoders those have been around for
a while so the new thing is to use a
variational step at the encoding layer
to sort of regularize my training and
i'll go into kind of what i mean about
that and just a little bit so in order
to to really just give you an example i
think it'd probably be best
to construct a network or like a simple
forward pass through one of these
networks and then you guys can construct
them on your own later on and try to
play around with them so there are a lot
of deep learning frameworks to use i'm
going to use chain ER because i think
it's nice and it's very readable it
might not be the best at benchmarking
and stuff but if you if you want to if
you want something to do you know rapid
prototyping it usually is quite useful i
think yeah tensorflow yeah so that came
out like right is right after I made
this presentation so that is not
included I actually haven't even looked
at dunster flow yet so I don't really
know its relative merits but I plan on
it at some point all right so a little
bit of an intro to Cheney right so this
is supposed to be an easy to use
framework for neural networks and it
really just has two basic building
blocks one of one of which is variables
which are just wrappers on ND arrays and
then the other are functions which
operate on variables and so given these
two processes basically what chain or
does is it kind of turns a variable into
both something that is numeric and
symbolic so when these function objects
act on the variable objects you get a
sequence of memorized operations right
so if I say two things we're added
together it is memorized that one of
those things was added to the other as
well as what the output of that adding
is right so it makes it go doing this
along the way by making these things
variables takes up a little bit more
memory for one but it also is immensely
helpful when you're doing back
propagation and auto differentiation
because then you just have all of the
different operations that you've done
and a nice computational graph in
sequence and you can just propagate
backward through that graph
differentiating along the way so just as
a simple example of kind of how this
works here I've kind of highlighted that
this I've taken X and Y which are just
ND arrays with one value in them five
and three and i'm highlighting here on
this computational graph what how things
are kind of being stored so x is stored
in this blue
32 box why I stored in this red one and
then as you filter down through the
sequence of operations you get a value Z
which is also a chain or variable and if
you call the attribute data it'll return
what the value of that is okay so you
can kind of inspect what your data is
doing but it also has this sequence this
memorized sequence of operations so all
of these different operations are stored
not the intermediate values but the fact
that they are operated on with a plus or
the fact that they were exponentiated
that's all stored in these chain or
variable objects and so that makes it
really nice to be able to go through and
calculate the gradients by just calling
dot backwards on my on my whatever
object I wish to calculate the backwards
gradients on so in order to define a
neural network model with this basically
I have to use something called a
function set which is just kind of wraps
all of my function objects together into
a model and and then I just have to
really just define a forward pass which
is just kind of how I want to structure
my network right and then I want to
define or I have to pick an optimizer
which is you know so oftentimes people
use gradient descent but some of the
more recent ones like Adam are the ones
that I've been using and then you just
want to make a script which basically
iteratively passes through that forward
loop calculates the gradients at the
very end and then passes those gradients
back through a back-propagation process
and then that's it's really easy to do
once you calculated your loss you just
call lost up backward and then optimizer
update and all of the weights are
updated for you how I'm defining oh yeah
that's so that's through auto
differentiation on like so you know
these are effectively symbolic variables
so it's not too hard to define the
gradients like going backward nope
that's all in change
no no this is like literally like
calling lost up but like I don't deal
with anything under the hood right like
calling lost backward is what I do and
then that actually calculates all of
those gradients for you know all that
all that stuff is written for me so I
definitely don't want to write auto
differentiation code yeah and so some of
the advantages of this or that you can
construct pretty intuitive forward
passes which are easily debugged because
you can mix inspect the data at
different times throughout the flow
right and then you can use sort of
arbitrary control flow statements in
some neural network packages like the
interpreter you need to like add in some
some things for control flow statements
with the interpreters backpropagation
super easy you like you saw you just
call dot backward and it does it for you
and then there's a really high level of
readability which I'm about to show you
here so so yeah let's build a simple
auto encoder so this is the model set up
part so you still have to kind of
declare you don't actually have to
declare it out right but it's helpful to
declare this and wrap it in this model
function so I basically just kind of
stored a dick of different layers these
f dot linear just correspond to linear
layers linear neural network layers of
different sizes and so I've structured
you know and coating layers decoding
layers wrap them up in this layers
[ __ ] and then use those as keyword
arguments for chain or function set and
that gives me a model back which has I
can call now model dot and code 0 thank
you and model dot and code one and it'll
it'll it'll apply this function later on
this parametric function and then I just
set up the model by saying optimizer I
pick my optimizer and then optimize your
setup and then I pass it the model and
everything is all set for me
this looks like PCA this this would look
like PCA so this this isn't actually the
full story right so like these linear
models are these linear layers if I just
had this that's true but well i'll show
you what i'm doing too I'm adding some
non-linearity in the mix too yeah so so
yeah so I structure it I start off with
an input here and I just make it a chain
or variable right so this is an image
for instance and then yeah so then I
pass it through this original linear
layer and then here's the non-pc a part
i call relew function on that so that's
a rectified linear unit which is you
know going to be nonlinear and then I'm
going to do that again and I'm going to
go down to a latent space which is
actually two times the dimension of what
I originally wanted my latent space to
be and the reason for that is that I'm
going to separate that I'm basically
just going to kind of have the latent
space and cleave it into two right i'm
going to call half of those parameters
means and half of them variances and
then i'm going to resample from normal
distributions with those parameters this
is the variational step and what that
effectively does is it injects noise
into the mix right because you know if I
just had a normal auto encoder but what
could happen feasibly if I don't have
enough image data is that I have enough
parameters here to effectively just
memorize all of my images right and so
that's no good like we don't want models
that are that are just going to memorize
your data they don't generalize very
well and they're pretty useless so
instead what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say that my latent encoding
space is somewhat probabilistic right so
I'm going to say that it's actually
drawn from a distribution a parametric
distribution is given by these normal
distributions with these parameters and
then I'm going to resample that and then
I'll pass those back through the
decoding section and so that's kind of
the variational step it injects noise in
the middle and some uncertainty so that
if I pass the same image through and
through I'm not going to get exactly the
same encoding and so it's really much
harder for me to actually memorized
those images by doing this you literally
just chop it in half yep and I'll show
you the exact code so so yeah so this
noise here yes
yeah you back prop I'll go into that
just a sec yeah okay so this is how you
back propagate against that this is to
prevent over-fitting yes yeah so you
back propagate against that by doing
this sort of Reaper amateur ization
trick which is to say that I take my
means and i are i take a standard normal
distribution and i'm just restating a
rescaling a standard normal to be
centered around a new mean with a new
variants by just multiplying by a
constant factor so that's how I'm kind
of how I'm doing it this is a paper
written by some other people which I'll
show you later but this is how they kind
of get around the issue of not being
able to back propagate through a
sampling layer yeah and then yeah and so
on the other side right you're just
doing the exact same thing on the output
end and then you have this sort of drop
in term which is a Gaussian KL
divergence and that really is just an
end i'm specifying a prior distribution
here of a normal distribution that
centered around 0 with a standard
deviation of one and what that
effectively does so the KL divergence is
actually measuring kind of how disparate
these two distributions are the ones
that I've trained with those muse and
sigmaz and the ones that are just normal
distributions with zero mean and
standard deviation 1 and so what that's
effectively doing is giving me a kind of
regularization process because it's
adding into my loss function something
which is going to give me a higher loss
if I have something which is further
away from the mean witch 0 and something
which is very low in standard deviation
so I was basically saying that if I'm
really certain about parameters which
are very different from 0 I better be
quite certain because it's going to cost
me in my loss function the end of the
day and then the other section is just
going to be my mean squared error okay
which is just what we talked about
earlier for the reconstruction and then
I go through and I back propagate and
that's pretty much it I'm running a
little low on time so I kind of wanted
to get to the results which is so after
after you do the process of this
training the nice thing is that you know
I can actually just throw away the
encoding part of the of this whole
process and I can pick you know
random parameters if I wanted to okay so
here I've actually initialized the
initial encoding to one of our shirts
and our our our inventory and I'm
actually picking we can kind of inspect
and see what's going on in these
dimensions by picking certain dimensions
and then ranging back and forth through
one of those parameters at a time so if
you will this is kind of the like this
is ranging back and forth over one of
the dimensions at a time so taking
specific slicing and you can see you
know there's there's some interesting
variation there's like short red shirt
tank top blue right they're not
supremely interpretable which is
somewhat unfortunate but we wouldn't
really expect them to be anyway what we
really hope at the end of the day is
from a modeling standpoint that they're
meaningful and then you can actually
just input random parameters altogether
and generate wholly new synthetic shirts
that you know are never before been seen
so this is kind of a fun thing to do I
like just generating random shirts from
time to time that's interesting people
have done this with other things which
I'm about to show you and you can do it
for yourself it's all up on github at
stitch fix / photograph and you can just
take the model it actually comes with
some command line tools which you know
you can pip install it also so you pip
install photograph it comes with some
command line tools to download an image
set which is a Hubble image set train a
simple model and then generate new
images based on what you've trained just
new random images all right so yeah
it all puts whatever it outputs yeah
because you've trained the the decoding
process right this generative process
you've trained on images in your data
set so then I get to pick you know some
some point in my vector space or my
multi-dimensional space and say hey what
image does that correspond to no I start
completely randomly yeah no yeah that's
what I mean is I start with a random 30
30 like 30 random numbers feed that
through the decoding step and then I get
these images back and so this is what
happens when you train it onto Hubble
stuff these are randomly generated
images from that so kind of the what it
thinks of is like I tried it on like
nebulae and galaxies and things so you
know what about what it thinks of as
those and then this is interesting
someone on Twitter had posted this he
did this process with the tool that I'd
mentioned on some images of faces so I
thought that was kind of cool the last
thing I wanted to mention is that
there's kind of an issue with this which
is just which is scaling to higher
resolution images so that's a big
problem right like we talked about
before this 60,000 node input right for
just a 100 x 200 image if we step down
which is a fairly aggressive step down
to four thousand as our next width of
our next layer that's already 240
million parameters for all of those if
you want to do a fully connected layer
for all those weights and a 32 bits of
peace that's 960 megabytes so for the
encoding and decoding you know you've
already got a two gig system and you've
only passed it through you know a
relatively small number of layers and so
if you want to do this and you
definitely want to do this probably on a
GPU for anything reasonably at scale
that's good not going to fit into memory
on your GPUs so you want at least your
model to fit into member have the GPUs
if not you know all of your data
so so there there's a solution which is
to basically reduce the number of
parameters before you start to pass it
through this fully connected set and you
do that by by passing it through
convolutional layers at the very
beginning and that kind of reduces your
parameter space before you pass it
through these fully connected layers and
that's actually coming soon it's
actually up on a branch on github right
now it works but I haven't fully tested
it yet so you know use at your own risk
there okay yeah and any questions oh I
should point out too i've written a blog
post it's up on the stitch fix
multi-threaded blog on this process and
it goes a little bit more into some of
the details behind the variational step
and so maybe you want to read that if
you're interested and there's the
original paper up at the top yeah yes
so effectively so what I'm doing the
reason that it's a variational auto
encoder has it rather than just an auto
encoders yeah so when I'm when I when I
get to my roughly my encoding layer
right I'm splitting the data apart so I
i generate a layer which is two times
the dimension that of what i actually
want i split it in half I call half of
that means in half of that variances and
then I sample from normal distribution
so from gaussians so these just standard
bell curves right I'm sampling from
those with those specific parameters so
I say it's centered around my mean the
bell curve centered around my mean and
its width is controlled by that variance
so for each pair I'm sampling and that's
that's the variational step that's the
step that's sort of injecting noise and
preventing some memorization of of this
of like these clothing items for
instance yes the sorry
you mean like do I cut it in half no I
don't cut anything I'm just I'm putting
in RAW images maybe it'd be nice to cut
it in half that would reduce my input
image by half yet no I don't do that
though there there are some there are
some patterning which would be hard to
do that with write on shirts so so it's
usually like unless you want to deal
with just solid things or just symmetric
shirts it's kind of hard to do that
the same person
yeah I'm not but that's not a bad idea I
could think about probably ways in which
you might want to do that yeah I would
have to think about it a little bit more
but no in short I haven't tried anything
like that yep actually using the same
GPU that before so all of this is done
on AWS with their GPU spot instances so
those come with four gigs of memory on
them and so yeah like you can go get one
of those and also trained on the GPU I
should mention that these command line
tools by also by default don't use GPU
that's an option so you have to specify
that when you when you try to use GPUs
on these yes pre-processing uh yeah you
know right so I thought about possibly
doing a PCA but you know that's
basically in effect kind of just adding
another layer onto the network but- like
modulo the nonlinear transformation at
the very end which is these relew layers
are these early functions yeah I didn't
try doing PCA I thought about it but I
kind of thought that that would at the
end of the day be a little bit more just
like well first off the reason that I
would want to do PCA is to do
dimensionality reduction right and if
I'm doing that then I'm not going to get
a nice invertible process to get back to
my original image so it's actually
really hard to use auto encoders if I if
I want to actually reduce the dimension
before in putting it through this auto
encoder process so that's that's
actually like kind of the reason that I
didn't do it but but you could think of
like possibly ways in which you might
just do pca as like a pre-processing and
then do some sort of like probabilistic
method on the back end to try to
reconstruct or maybe not do pca on the
back end to to reconstruct but add just
an additional layer to your neural
network something and it will learn
those proper parameters yeah
oh I should mention by the way I mean
you mean like in general or just like
with this process because this is not
actually in production yet so I've been
testing this but like this is not
something that we're currently doing to
try to like do modeling wait yeah so in
general I mean we take lots of input
from our stylists in terms of like lots
of interface things we've we like and
whether or not like they feel like the
things that are being presented to them
are better or worse definitely there's a
lot of stylist input that goes into that
at the end of the day we have pretty
hard metrics for whether or not
something was successful you know
whether or not someone kept an item of
clothing or not whether or not there you
know satisfaction rating was high or low
so so we tend to focus on those a little
bit more but yeah we definitely take
south and put it into account as well
oh yeah how does it go a little bit of a
point of tension for a little while yeah
we were we were sort of thinking about
constructing our own you know GPU box
the problem with that is that you know
and a lot of people kind of want to use
it and then they get expensive because
you have to buy more of them and then
you have to maintain them and then
there's these you know information
security sorts of reasons you know you
don't want to have to like always log
into those and in your internal firewall
and yeah so it's much nicer just to do
it on AWS I started off doing scripts
now i'm using a jupiter notebook to
interface with it just because i get way
more feedback right away and i don't
have to like pull down images that I've
generated when I'm like inspecting what
it's doing so yeah it's nice i guess i
can just present them on the screen cool
okay thanks everyone thank you very much